foreign  how many times you willing to get burned  before you stop trusting someone  how many times you got to take a bullet  for these [ __ ] in the name of  empty promises  politicians military Runners  intelligence operatives all the Run fish  in one [ __ ] Barrel this dog town  tell me you've got a plan not a plan  a man  there's anyone we can trust now it's him  Solomon real f.i.a  so what do we do now  dog town running to the grounds what  we'll do it's a simple choice  them or us  peace comes at a price someone's always  got to pay  game awards what's up get yourself ahead  I just want to let you know how excited  I am to play Musa agent Solomon Reed in  cyberpunk 2077 Phantom Liberty can't  wait for you guys to meet read and  Phantom Liberty releases in 2023  see you in night City  [Applause]